we're here again in the beautiful
YouTube space New York in a studio
filled with lights and camera and now
some action this particular action is
going to be talking about how computers
can help countries get along a little
better today we're going to talk about
machine translation and how it doesn't
go so well in the early days hey ah the
80s well known for great fashion sense
but guys with cheesy Russian accents and
fears of nuclear annihilation
maybe it's the coder in me but I have
actually always wondered if the Cold War
would have been a bit well you know
warmer if computers could have helped us
understand each other
it turns out we tried just that welcome
to compchomp the only show on the
internets where there's something colder
than a Russian winter let me take you
back in time - lovely 1948 computers
were a thing a new thing a big room
sized thing that you had to feed with
little tiny paper punched holes these
binary loving behemoths were so
successful that folks actually started
wondering if there was any problem they
couldn't solve and one of those folks
that definitely couldn't ignore their
power was mr. Warren Weaver fear the
mighty power of the computer he kept
bugging all of his colleagues hey guys
you know what you know what computers
should be doing guys guys my my idea
about computers in Russian and they're
like dude Weaver we have told you a
million times you need to stop bothering
us and just write this stupid Russian
thing down he sat down and he wrote the
very first memo on computer translation
and it really got the ball rolling
first UCLA in Georgetown got on board
and then MIT followed in 1951 by giving
yahushua bar-hillel the position of
full-time professional machine
translation math the first in the
business then in 1954 IBM in georgetown
staged the first public demo of machine
translation 49 whole russian sentences
the crowd went wild in T was the next
big thing so how did they do it well
they started with the Russian sentence
I broke it into its dictionary chunks
you know word and word pieces like
suffixes and roots then they applied one
of just six rules to the chunks for
example here is the first rule no no
wait
we are programmers we count from zero so
this is the zeroeth rule a word was
associated with the code 110 and that
code told the machine to go back and
look at the last full word and when it
found that last word it had to check
that word for another code 21 and if
that word came up 21s the Machine placed
it after the first word now I know that
sounds like a whole bunch of steps but
the result was pretty simple you take
two words and you switch them with only
a fistful of rules like this the machine
translated amazing sentences like mmm
magnitude of angle is determined by the
relation of length of Arc to radius and
the price of potatoes is determined by
the demand potatoes really machine
culturally sensitive much in spite of
that the journalists were impressed and
the public they were stunned in a world
that had never seen computer smarts like
this this was magic but uh if you peer
behind that curtain a little bit things
start to feel a tiny bit less magical
the sentences had all been carefully
selected everything was transliterated
from Cyrillic into the Latin alphabet
and grammatically sentences included
only third-person verbs and avoided any
negations or questions sometimes things
that we would think of as grammar or
syntax were stored as part of the
dictionary entries and that last one is
actually pretty cheap think about it
this machine associates each Russian
word with up to two dictionary entries
so there's a word that translates to
relation but if you look at the second
English choice it's the relation instead
of figuring out a way to train the
computer to understand English articles
they just shove the word V in as part of
another dictionary choice so yeah they
were doing a little bit of cheating but
I only cheated a little bit but it did
not matter to the public people were
really excited and if you were a
translating machine the times were good
for now because when we return to wrap
up this story
things start to get ugly the nerds are
going to be fighting over how computers
should be translating and the public
starts making a mockery of grammar and
the very existence of machine
translation will hang in the balance
chime